hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today we're
gonna work with react I wasn't exactly
sure what would be working on so I left
the title nice and vague and just said
react coding so we're probably gonna
finish up or at least try to do a little
bit more with that form that we were
working with yesterday I I thought I
might be able to get it finished before
the stream but I wasn't really able to
do that much so I had kind of a long
meeting this morning and but it was a
good meeting though it started out with
food so he had breakfast which is really
nice and then then we had like our
normal meeting afterwards which took
longer longer than normal but I still
wanted to get a streaming so today we
might be a little bit shorter than
normal
we'll see how it goes to may only end up
doing one Pomodoro session of code so
for everyone who's new this livestream
is just me doing my everyday work
I'm a full-time front-end developer and
I worked for a small university so this
is not rehearsed at all I will make
mistakes I think maybe one time I did a
stream where everything worked out well
so but I'll make mistakes we'll work
through them I'll answer your questions
and I'll try to narrate what I'm doing
as we go along I break things up with
Pomodoro sessions so we'll do 25 minutes
of just mostly coding and I won't really
look at the live chat too much and then
I'll take a five-minute break and I'll
answer your questions in the chat and
then at the end of the stream if there
are any questions remaining I'll take as
much time as I need to get through all
the other questions so like I said for
today maybe we'll just do one Pomodoro
session and the rest will be questions
so I did get into work really early like
way order later than normal this morning
so I'm gonna be leaving earlier than
normal
[Music]
so I don't want to do want to say too
long with the stream and all right so
let's get started I'm gonna check the
chat first before we saw our timer and
do some code so hey a few people saying
hi how's it going thanks for joining us
[Music]
Anna is through the emoji that she's put
on there this thinks it's funny that I
put the description as I'm not sure
exactly what we're going to work on
today but I'm pretty sure it was
something to do with react.js yeah I
mean that's that's the best I could come
up with for the description because I
really didn't know how far I would get
with what I was working on and anoop
says I have a static website and react
which has client-side rendered which is
client-side rendered I would like to
know how I can convert it to service had
rendered website if it were me
personally I would just start up I would
build a react project with next Jas and
I would literally just copy and paste
the components over then you're gonna
get server-side rendering already built
in the only thing that might be weird is
like if you wanted to then use the
routing from next Jas you might have to
change some things that's what I would
do there may be an easier way to do that
but I don't know about it you know
offhand so if I had a little bit more
time I personally would probably
research it first
but if I needed to get it server-side
rendering as fast as possible I would go
the next day s route because I already
know how to do that let's see
we have a high from Guadalajara Mexico
awesome welcome if I just see really
like your videos because you're showing
the normal expert web developer would
you recommend me to be a react developer
in 2019 Thanks
oh yeah for sure I think there's a lot
of jobs and react it's a lot of fun to
develop with so if you're interested in
react and you think you'll enjoy working
with it then for sure yeah go for it I
see react jobs being posted like
constantly I was just at react rally
last week and there were a lot of
companies there that we're looking for
react developers even like big companies
were there like Apple was there
American Express was there and then some
smaller companies like formidable labs
not slip in my mind there was this other
company that had this really cool like
editor website editor product it was all
built with react and I can't starts with
the W and it's up in my mind but anyway
you know I believe every single like
company that had a booth that react
rally was hiring and wanted react
developers specifically so in any case I
think it's it's definitely a good way to
go
I mean react is still young right it's
it's only been out for I mean what like
four years or something like that and
you know during the first year everybody
thought it it was crazy anyway so I mean
it's it's still growing high from India
all right cool I'm gonna get started so
I've been spent about six minutes on the
intro stuff so let's get started if
anybody wants to follow along with the
code there's a link to the the github
repo in the description and we are on
the Salesforce branch so make sure you
switch it up for master
it's a Salesforce otherwise the codes
gonna look different for what we're
working on today we'll be working on the
component called inquiry Jas let me
switch my screen so you can see and I'm
gonna make my font a lot bigger and you
can see here in the components folder
where an inquiry and I have updated the
github repo with the latest code I will
say this the latest code has some errors
in it but I just wanted to make sure it
was all there on github so I pushed it
anyway but let me catch you up on what
I've done and then explain what we're
gonna do and we'll we'll do some code
let me start my Pomodoro timer so
basically what I've added is a dialog
component this is from material you I so
we needed to bring in a dialog and this
will be basically like a little modal
that pops up when you submit the form so
I'm still not sure if I want to go with
a modal or just some type of small
loading indicator the reason that I
thought of going with the modal is
because well two reasons number one I
already had the code for that ready from
another project so it was easy to copy
and paste it but also the number two
reason is I may want to give the user
more information and I think a modal
would easily let me do that
maybe prompt them to even do do more so
I'm not exactly sure how I want to do
that yet so for now that's what's gonna
be in there what would happen is the
motor would open it would say that it's
still sending the data and then when we
get confirmation that the data has been
sent successfully
then it will switch over and say success
or something like that and then prompt
the user to either like just close the
modal or potentially I don't know take
the next step give us some more info I'm
not exactly sure yet
it's gonna be somewhat up to our
admissions department here because
they're the ones that need that data and
are gonna be acting on that okay oh oh
Sean asked for the dev site link yeah
let's
I wonder there we go let's start up
Angra so n grok will allow you all to
see what I'm working on on your local
machines so if you click that link or
copy and paste that link you should be
able to see the site and the stuff that
we're doing will show up on the home
page so you shouldn't have to navigate
anywhere of course you can if you want
to and check out you know other pages on
the site and let me pull it over on the
screen - and that way for those of you
who who can't be in a computer right now
looking at it you'll still be able to
see what we're we're working on so I
have it all on a other screen right now
and I'm just gonna move it over here and
I'll show you what we have so here's
what we have the the form that working
on is right here it looks really bad
right now so we're gonna work on the
look of it a little bit but these are
the these are the fields that we'll have
so these are not likely to change we'll
just have these four fields first name
last name email and student type and you
can pick undergrad graduate and online
and then we have a submit button that
right now I don't know what's up with
that so what I'll have to fix the
styling on that also like the I don't
know why this is all the way over here
it's something to do with the container
I guess so we definitely have some
styling work that needs to be done and
that might actually be a good thing to
do like this your style is a little bit
better because even if I can't get it to
work if I have it sty
correctly by the time I have to present
this it'll be fine right because if I'm
presenting it nobody's gonna actually be
clicking anything right I'm just gonna
be scrolling down telling everybody what
it does so it makes more sense to just
kind of make it look good now and then
we can make it work after so let's work
on that so we have let me show you how
we're doing styling so we have this
object it's actually basically like CSS
but you see there are some differences
so we go with camel case instead of
hyphenated terms here so you know font
size is capital S right no hyphen and
then anything that's a string needs to
go in quotes numbers can just be numbers
right but it's in the format of a
JavaScript object okay so that's what
we'll be using mostly for our Styles
here so first things first let's get
that container into shape so our stuffs
not like super spread out so I like the
container size that we already have here
right so you have some space on the
sides so let's just try to match that
for now and then we can go from there
and see see how it looks yeah I'm
actually gonna I'm gonna turn on my fan
yeah just keep it on low if it's too
noisy let me know but I don't know if
you can see like I'm super hot and I
feel like my forehead is just super
shiny because I'm starting to sweat so
apologies for that I probably looks
gross but it's just got really hot in my
office okay if you're just coming in
you're wondering why I'm not looking at
your question then chat I will look at
your question as soon as this Pomodoro
timer is up so in about 20 minutes so
just hang in there a little bit and I
will be sure to look at your comment and
answer any questions that you might have
so we have this grid container let's see
where that ends yeah you know what
actually let's see this is we need to go
back to our index page right because
that's where all the other containers
are so this inquiry ojs is its own
component and we're just putting it into
the index page here right here into
inquiry and on the index page I think
what we have is that are our main grid
is not what's giving us our padding on
the sides
it's these grid items each have their
own padding so I'm gonna verify that in
our CSS object which let's move that
down so we're currently moving all of
our CSS to the bottom of our components
that makes it a bit easier to figure out
what a component does when you first
open it so we're gonna look at those
various content we have a content
container actually our content container
should be regulating its double check
what class we have one here
yeah our grid container does have the
class of content container and our
inquiry is within that container so
we're gonna have to dig a little bit
deeper to figure out why this inquiry
component is not fitting in there so
let's see first off let's see what kind
of styles we have here
and we grabbed some of these styles
let's get rid of because they were from
when we we used a different component as
our base and then we just kind of edited
it so those styles were from a different
component yes we don't have any styles
in here right now
that I think would would really mess
anything up hmm I don't even think we're
using this form control let's see if
it's on the page I guess we are no okay
we are using a form control somewhere
okay
so let's go back to let's go back to
this and let's just inspect it see
what's going on I will make this bigger
so y'all can see and
let's see what section so we're dealing
with this section here okay so we'll
just do a quick comparison here so we
have this grid container and it's saying
we have a width of 100% let's compare it
to this grid container which also has a
width of 100% but then it has a max
width of 70 interesting you know what I
think is going on let's look back at our
index component I thought let us close
this off interesting okay so I thought
that this grid container was not closed
but evidently it is closed and it closes
here okay that makes more sense now
let's
let's put another grade container here
I'm not sure if this is the best way to
handle this but I I'm gonna try it first
this thing I'm thinking is maybe we
could just extend it and put this
inquiry inside our existing grid
container and we could probably do put
this in there as well or potentially we
could add the styles for the grid
container on the container that's in our
other component which I wouldn't like to
do because I'll make it a bit less
versatile and then the only other thing
I'm worried about is we're gonna have a
container grid container within a grid
container I'm not sure how how that's
gonna work but we'll find out so for now
it looks like it's okay it is within
that yeah so it's staying within there
in terms of the layout let's see what it
looks like
so we have this outer container and then
we have a inner container and then we
have another one so I guess it doesn't
really matter it's just kind of like an
extra unnecessary dev which they're not
a huge deal so I think we'll go with it
for now
so that gives us a little bit of padding
Hey look our submit button now actually
says submit that's cool I don't know
what the deal was before but I probably
end up styling that differently maybe to
look more like like this button does but
for now it you know we get the idea that
there's a submit button it would it
actually might be nice if you all let me
know what you think about this so when
the screen small this doesn't look too
bad but when it starts to get big this
is just a huge gap between like all
these fields so I'm thinking we need to
do something about that
so either we could go with the fields
being like all on one line on a large
screen and then starting to stack as the
screens get smaller or we can set a like
a fixed max width so that we get the
width we like and it'll never go bigger
than that
let's try both let's let's see though so
let me know what you all think in the
chat and then I'm just gonna try both
right here so you can see them and I'll
be able to see him and see what I like
so first first thing and it'll be really
easy is let's just add in everywhere
that we have this SM equals 6 we're
gonna switch that up and we'll leave it
for the small screens or 6 but now we're
gonna say MD for medium size equals 3
actually 5 of these I think because if
we count the submit button it's it's 5
so we could go with this is gonna be
weird yeah let's go with 3 let's have it
take up 3 columns for now that is gonna
leave that 5th one kind of like on the
end there like down below but you can't
really divide 12 by 5 evenly so we'll
just try this first okay so now when
there's a large screen it does go across
I'm gonna submit button below I don't
know I'm not sure that I really love
that either
look at it just for a second let you all
have a chance to look at it
okay
I think it potentially would look a lot
better if we had it like inside a
section like this that had a dark
background I'm not gonna try it out
right now though we could try it out
maybe in a minute cuz then I'd have to
change the font color and everything so
we're just gonna imagine it for right
now
eventually I do want to do it though
because I'd like to put this same these
same fields in the footer and obviously
I'd need to change the font color for
that alright so the next thing I'm going
to try is we'll switch it back to how it
was and then we'll we'll just have a max
width I get to the end of my playlist
you need to switch this up
okay we're good now can't possibly code
without Spotify on right
okay
so we'll just undo all that and now
let's put Chad to see if we already had
styles on here but I guess we don't do
we have styles on anything yeah we do
trying to copy and paste and avoid
typing as much as possible so on our
grid container let's add this and we'll
just say container and then let's go
down here and add a class for container
and we'll say max width let's give it a
max width of 300 pixels and that'll
actually work no matter what even on
mobile because as far as I know the
narrowest mobile device still has 320
pixels so this should be good
I've seen a lot of stuff down here what
is happening
oops forgot a comma so remember this is
the same syntax as a JavaScript object
because in fact it is a JavaScript
object so we do need to have these
commas in here so that should work yep
that works now oh all right so first
problem with that is that we have
overlapping fields
all right so it's not gonna work being
that small so let's go in here and see
remember we're just trying to get a feel
for what it looks like so what I'm gonna
do now is just change things in dev
tools just so that we can see it without
the overlapping fields so here's the
container that we put that max width on
let's bump it up to 600 pix yeah 600 it
looks way better and let's also give
this to flex let's go with Flex align
items
no that's not what I want justify
content there we go so since we're using
flexbox we can say justify Content
Center on this containing div and this
will move everything to the middle I
just kind of wanted to see what it would
look like in the middle I don't like
that this is on on the side here
alright let me do a little bit with this
just to see what it'll look like whoops
there we go so let's move this down all
right so our container we're gonna bump
to 6-under 600 pixels and then within
that let's go to justify content see a
content oops forget that comma again if
you have justify content we're gonna say
Center and then we're also going we're
gonna go up here and find that submit
I'm gonna find that submit button and
we're gonna switch this so that it takes
up the full amount of space and then I
don't really want that to be centered
either so let me wait a second on that
so I want to see what it looks like
first so let's go back here to this
containing div so verify that now it is
taking up the full width right which is
what we wanted and we could say let's
let's say aligned self and see what we
can get here whoops
is that the wrong one I wonder why it's
doing that
oh I know it's the problem is there an
equivalent in flexbox to aligned self
but I guess I can go with this div and
let's let's just say justified content
I'm gonna end that's weird
yeah we should be able to we should be
able to do this
what am I doing wrong
all right about two more minutes till I
go to the chat and answer questions so
I'm messing something up here
john hanson saying put the submit button
in its own flex div what's the thing I
thought it already was it's not
surface
all right
alright let's try that this would be the
last thing that we do
styles
so this
display flex oops flex and then justify
content and
except with this
it's my problem it's come on oops
shouldn't have evil is there
alright see what that did nothing
refresh to make sure we're clearing
anything that might still be in here all
right
Oh Michael Cruz saying use flex and yet
maybe that's my problem
yeah flex in it was that the whole time
all right cool
and then now I've lost my formatting for
this
for whatever reason this is not working
now
all right I mainly just wanted to see if
the submit button would look better over
here now that I see it I'm not so sure
but my timer is up so I'm gonna put on
this five-minute timer just to see if
maybe we want to do another Pomodoro
session but for now I'm thinking maybe
not we'll see how it goes
in any case I do still want your opinion
on what to do with with this form in
terms of style so the only constraints
basically are we need those fields and a
submit button and it has to be like
material design looking okay so other
than that you know we do whatever we
want with it
so if you have ideas please let me know
cute success react versus known vs.
angular so I would say nodes shouldn't
be included in there because node can
and usually is used with both react and
angular so note is back-end reacts
versus angular I mean it's really a
matter of preference they're not exactly
the same like comparable you know one to
one they do some different things but I
mean the only thing that I'll say in
terms of difference is react is growing
at a faster rate then angular in terms
of like usage right but angular is still
widely used so I haven't used any of the
newer versions of angular so I really
can't say much more about it
John Hanson also said okay so there's a
question earlier about server-side
rendering with react john hanson
recommends gatsby j/s so I had mentioned
next j/s that's what we're using for
this project but John says check out
Gatsby so yeah I haven't used Gatsby on
a project but I was pretty impressed
with it when we we checked it out as a
potential solution for this particular
project Lara said lar says how to build
a C++ website I have no idea I've never
attempted to build a website in C++ in
general though if you're gonna build a
website you're gonna use HTML and CSS
I mean HTML at the very least minimum
write CSS if you want it to look nice if
you wanted to do anything you're going
to need JavaScript your your any other
language you're using is going to be
back end so you can use whatever you
want for the back end but you definitely
need to know HTML CSS and JavaScript if
you're gonna do anything with the web
Kartik s's says no air conditioner in
your room yeah I mean there is air
conditioning in this building it's just
my room gets really warm I think it's
because of all my my screens generate
like heat so other rooms like other
offices in my building are they're
generally pretty cool but I just have a
heat source in mine
boom man says what do you think about
Redux is it needed for small project no
I generally I think Redux is not
necessary for a small project you
usually the point at which I start
considering Redux is if I find myself
passing props down like through a number
of children or like back up to the
number of like parent and grandparent
elements so if I need to pass things
like three levels down or more and then
I'm gonna consider Redux or something
like Redux otherwise just manage state
the way reiax was was intended right
it's just with local like component
state I think you'd be fine like that
and you're gonna because like Redux just
adds all this extra complexity and it it
will slow you down
for a small project if you don't really
need it if you have a large project
Redux will eventually save you time but
there's a point at which it would
actually save you time so if you haven't
reached that point in terms of project
complexity it's it's less efficient to
use Redux so hopefully that makes sense
let me know if it doesn't okay my
five-minute timer is up but I'm just
gonna keep going with some questions
right now
okay Michael krill says the form control
is wrapping the select okay so that's
probably why the select is not taking up
this full space because it's inside of
another container alright cool
I'm glad you notice that
on couche says which language we're
using javascript Michael crow says I
thought you said it was gonna end up
being a modal the form itself won't be a
modal but once you submit the form a
modal will pop up John Hanson says we
can easily nest Reed containers since
their flex box nested true CSS grids
have a few gotchas okay cool so we
should be fine nesting it I mean it
looks a bit messy but you know not that
many people are gonna be inspecting our
code and my eyes look super red right
now I don't know why I've been so tired
I just can't recover from my trip I
didn't get that much sleep like last
week and I'm still like exhausted all
the time maybe I'm starting to get sick
actually that kind of makes sense maybe
it's like the early early stages of
meeting sick I hope not but it's
definitely possible
Williams what programming you discussing
JavaScript in particular react
alright Michael crow says you said a
whiff on the items against the viewport
set an absolute value for the container
okay that must have been before we we
did that so I think we that's in fact
what we ended up doing
Williams says how can I become a
developer I know the basics of
programming which I studied in
engineering if you're very new to being
a web developer check out free code camp
org and start to go through some of the
lessons there they are very helpful and
it will take you through a lot of the
basics all the way ended with some more
advanced stuff as you go on and that
should give you a good idea of you know
what you need to know and whether or not
you even like working with with that
kind of thing
Lenovo as how was your trip to New York
City it was good so yeah let me I don't
know if I said anything about my trip
yeah or at least explain that much about
it so last week I actually took two
trips first I went to react rally in
Salt Lake City and then I flew to New
York in particular I was in Williamsburg
Brooklyn
Brooklyn is a section of New York City
and there was a free code camp Top
Contributors party so I was was honored
to be one of the top contributors for
2018 so went there it was really cool it
was awesome to meet a lot of these
people that I had contact with online
and I'd never met in person so that was
really cool and there are a lot of
people that were doing things that I
didn't even realize that they were
working with free code camp and after
getting to meet him and learning about
what they were doing you know I was wow
this is awesome you know I know your
work even though I didn't know you yes I
mean some of the people I met you know
moderated the forum and some of them
were editors for the medium publication
or worked with a podcast or worked on
like the actual code for free code camp
so it was cool it was really cool
there's a lot of fun so we just kind of
hung out
ate food and stuff and and the whole
thing was live streamed so you can check
that out the the videos available on
this YouTube channel so this it was a
good cool experience and then I just the
rest of the time I thought I was there I
I just decided to walk around New York
and see what it was like so I took like
during the day I walked all around
Brooklyn and and just checked out as
much as I could I walked around until my
phone died and then I charged it a bit
and then that that night so this would
be Sunday night I went to Manhattan and
walked around Manhattan for hours and
hours and Hill my phone was about to die
so that was cool so I mean I stopped in
a lot of places got you know food or
coffee or something I had the best ramen
I've ever eaten in my life in Manhattan
it was awesome that it's on katsu style
ramen was so good but anyway yeah it was
cool it's cool to just get see what it's
like Brooklyn and Manhattan are super
different yeah it's just so so different
so it's kind of cool you know like you
go to New York it's not it's not just
all the same not all one city like each
part is definitely distinct its own like
type of people stores like architecture
it's it's cool it was a really cool trip
and Salt Lake City was a cool place -
way different from New York but but also
a cool cool place to be so if anybody
wants to know more about my trip or
anything specific feel free to ask me in
the chat here or at some other time I'd
be happy to talk more about it otherwise
I don't want to bore you if you're not
interested
Shradha says the toad is so blurry so if
your code is blurry I'm guessing that it
might be the connection so it should be
I'm streaming in 1080p quality so in
1080p and I think 2 in 720 the codes
shouldn't be blurry but anything lower
than that it's blurry so if you're not
getting a good picture right now you can
wait and watch the recording and you may
be able to watch in Full HD if you have
a good network connection you know later
on the other thing it could be if you're
watching on a mobile device it's really
hard to watch code on a mobile device so
it doesn't really matter how big I make
the code it's still gonna look kind of
small alexei says how to match our CSS
we're just practice work with it a lot
so you can watch videos and do courses
on it which is great but no matter what
you do just practice everyday or as
close as you can get to everyday I think
that's the key to getting good at really
anything so that's that's my advice for
CSS and for pretty much everything else
you just try to do at least a little bit
every day
Kardec says angular has MVC so
model-view-controller which is not and
react is it important it it depends on
what you want to do right if your
project lends itself better to that kind
of architecture the
model-view-controller
then then go with that like if not it so
I mean it's really when we're talking
about let's say like angular versus
react sources view or ember or jQuery
whatever else you want to compare it to
right a lot of times you want to say
like and I get these questions a lot
like which one's the best like like
there's a best like that's the answer
right but it's not that clear-cut it it
usually comes down to what are you
trying to accomplish
like let's pick the tool right trying it
asking which is the best between like
angular or whatever you want ask is kind
of like asking what's the best tool
right hammer versus screwdriver versus
wrench which is the best it depends
entirely on what you're trying to do
right if you're trying to hammer a nail
obviously the hammer is the best all
right but if you try to take a screw and
drive it into a piece of wood with a
hammer it's not gonna be nearly as
effective as if you had a screwdriver if
you have a bulb right like you're gonna
want a wrench so think of frameworks in
encoding like that right it's not that
this one thing that's better
in all cases it's what is your use case
and what's gonna be the best thing for
you you want something that's going to
do what you need it to do but not come
with all this extra stuff that you don't
need so that it's bloated right it may
be call it take you a lot more time to
set something up that has lots of extra
stuff that you don't need sometimes the
best thing is just to pick the most
simple solution that fits your use case
even if that solution in terms of total
features is way less feature filled than
something else right you also want to
think about like on your team of
developers what
they already know right learning
something new even if that new thing
might be better is going to take a long
time is it is that better thing going to
add enough value to the project to to
make sense in like all that extra time
that you're going to need to give your
developers to learn it right it doesn't
always pay off right sometimes it makes
more sense to go with the older thing or
the thing that's not it doesn't have as
many features if you're developers
already know it if you need to get that
thing out quickly right because you get
the product out quickly and it works
then you can move on to the next product
right and make a lot more money assuming
that you can fulfill all your clients
requirements it doesn't have to be like
I'm using the absolute latest cutting
cutting it's perfect thing it's do i
fulfill the requirements of the projects
right and that's what should be your
focus should be so for me
react makes sense for a lot of things
one of the big reasons is I know react
right it would take me a while to learn
something new but there are some cases
where even react is overkill and I might
say okay for this project like I'm just
gonna do straight up HTML CSS if I need
some interactivity I'll do vanilla
JavaScript maybe even jQuery sometimes
it needs to get loaded for something
else on the page anyway and in that case
I would just use it right so that's
where I think we need to look at that
question sorry for like the the rant on
that but you know I get I get that
question often enough that I think it is
kind of worth explaining this that it's
you know these frameworks are not it's
not competition right they often borrow
ideas from each other and build off of
each other and they are created to solve
different problems so I think the tool
analogy is is pretty good here right you
just need to find the tool that is meant
for your problem and
and not think that somehow there's one
tool that's gonna solve everything right
and and sometimes it doesn't matter if
you pick the wrong thing it'll still
work right like if you pound hard enough
you can get a screw into a board with a
hammer but it's going to take a lot more
effort and it's not gonna fit as
perfectly but it's possible right so you
know don't be afraid of um am I gonna
pick the wrong framework just get
started start working if it's really the
wrong thing for you it'll you'll notice
and hopefully you'll have time to switch
but even if you don't you could probably
still make it work
let's see lost my place it's gonna be
down automatically david ass is react is
still an on-demand javascript library
yes definitely i think i mentioned
earlier i see a ton of jobs that are
asking for react experience so yeah so
your your good if you know react if
you're gonna learn react there are jobs
out there Stephen says any plans for
using graph QL yeah we are using graph
QL on this project so we didn't work
with it today but we will work with it
again in the future and we have worked
with it on on past streams
Shradha says how do I get this code from
the start stage I guess you'd have to
look back at some of the like the
earliest commits and then view the repo
at that point
and they're linked to the repos in the
description some pieces don't die I will
try not to die I think as I mentioned I
think I was getting sick earlier shroud
I said is this session over sir
the coding portion is over I don't think
I'm gonna do any more coding today
because I'm actually gonna leave the
office really soon but I'm still going
to do questions
AJ asked any tips for making a sticky
footer anyway to point me in the
direction to the one you use on your
current site so a sticky footer you mean
like all right so I'm not exactly sure
what you mean by that do you mean that
you would always be able to see the
footer and it would always be visible as
you scroll or or do you mean that the
footer would always be at the bottom
even if you were on a page that didn't
have enough content to push it to the
bottom so I guess if you wanted the
footer to always be visible then I guess
you're gonna want to set it to something
like absolute position right or I'm
sorry a fixed position right and you're
gonna want to set in fixed position
right like 100 oh actually Mike will
Michael criolla is the answer here so so
just check out what he wrote I'll
explain it for those of you who maybe
can't see the live chat right now
basically you would set it at position
fixed and then you would do for the
value it would be you would say top
right for the positioning and then you'd
use calc so calculate you do math inside
of CSS so you would want to say 100 VH
that's the viewport height so that would
position it with the top corner down
here so you wouldn't actually be able to
see it but then you do calc minus the
height of your footer right so whatever
that might be and that would bump it up
by the height of your footer so then the
footer would always be there always
visible as you scroll down all right so
that's that's how you would do that if
that's what you mean by sticky otherwise
if you just always wanted it to be at
the bottom even if you didn't have
enough content to push it to the bottom
you would want to put your content in
one container right maybe call it main
or something and then make the minimum
height of that container be 100
vh- the height of the footer and then
potentially if you might want to take
into account the height of the header as
well depending on what you have the
header set at Medina says hello from
Bangladesh hey how's it going thanks for
for joining us let's see Louie Louie's
how do you pronounce that in France
anyway says hi from France how's it
going thanks for joining us Michael says
it must have been nice when you
introduced yourself on the stream hi I'm
Jesse and most of them got the reference
so yeah on the if you watch the free
code camp Top Contributor party live
stream when they got around to me which
was kind of when they were doing
introductions I was almost the last one
I got on the mic I said hey you know
everyone it's Jesse from like coding
with Jesse which is pretty close to what
I say at the beginning of every stream
and a lot of people did laughs they they
got the reference so it was it was fun
Vonn she says do you use sass with JSX
you can use sass with with reacts it's
possible we're not in this particular
project but we have in past projects if
you're talking about actually having
sass like in your JSX code I've never
seen that happen it's usually in a
separate file
Michael creo says except so this is
earlier I said there's not really one
JavaScript library framework that solves
all your problems right that's always
the best solution and Michael creo says
except duct tape duct tape is always
useful in any circumstance duct tape is
quite useful for many different things
John Hanson says duct tape works when
everything is there a new dev flat form
duct tape jas that's a good idea
somebody better grab that domain duct
tape dot IO or something put up like a
placeholder NPM package called duct tape
meant mammy
let me know if I'm pronouncing that
wrong but mammy says hello Jessie I
listen because I see now I will not get
good at this I have to see it even with
the desktop too small for me and it says
me because I want to legally blind Oh No
hmm I'm not sure what I can do
do you think if I made the font even
bigger it would help or does it not
really matter with the the font size is
I mean I could probably make it a little
bit bigger than I have it right now
it needs I mean there's definitely an
upper limit to where we wouldn't be able
to see enough on the screen to really
understand anything
but let me know I can definitely try to
make it larger for you
I thought she says alright enough
talking you get to work
I'm gonna get through all the questions
alex is aloof from bazoo I'm gonna
stress all that earlier so hey Alex
Karthik says how do I get ideas for a
project in react I'm not creative if you
just check out like app ideas or
something like that like if you google
that you'll see their whole lists and in
websites dedicated to ideas for for web
projects so check that out and you could
just pick whatever one you you like he
says I did that footer it's just some
flexbox the idea is you set display flex
on your container and a min height of
100 VH then declare flex one on the main
item okay cool so evidently Nikki said
to set this up for the footer for this
site Thank You Nikki I that was probably
one of the first things that we did so
that was so long ago I had forgotten
about that but thanks for that and
thanks for explaining how you did it
getting ass Nass I don't know if the G
is supposed to be silent on that but
it's GNA s says can you compare CSS
animation versus JavaScript animation
yeah from what I understand which maybe
is limited if you can do animation CSS
performance wise it's almost always
better to do it in CSS versus JavaScript
hey but javascript is gonna allow you to
do more than you can do with CSS right
although there's a lot you can do with
CSS right you'd be surprised at how much
how much is possible if your CSS so but
as a general rule if you can do
something with pure CSS and it's it's
not going to be like ridiculously
complicated and it will be supported and
the browsers that you need to support
then you want to try to do it with CSS
otherwise I mean there's nothing wrong
with doing with JavaScript a ton of
websites use javascript for animation
but you might get a slight you know
performance increase if you can do it
with CSS aleksey says do you use CSS
modules and react components are they
used
in general basically the way you see us
using CSS here is pretty much the way
that we we always do it so we do some
inline CSS we do CSS and in JavaScript
as those objects and then we also have
just regular CSS files that we we pull
in just by you know putting it in the
head of our page components hmm sorry
sorry for the yarn I've been trying to
hold him back so anyway that's what we
do with CSS I haven't really messed with
very much of anything else I have tried
styled components I don't really have
experience using CSS module stuff as is
they it easyyy not sure how to pronounce
that let me know and I'll try to
pronounce it correctly next time says hi
from Nigeria how's it going thanks for
watching
all right so Nikki posted a link github
link to a sticky footer demo and it was
held for review I just saw it and proved
it now so if you scroll back up it's not
too far from the bottom but you'll see
Nikki's link so that might help anybody
who's looking to do sticky footer with
flexbox
javascript is a JavaScript asset going
JavaScript axe did you asks did you see
the updates to JavaScript dot AF I have
not I haven't seen in a while so in case
you wondering what that is I own the
domain name JavaScript AF and some of
the live stream viewers have been
working on it on the side so in
particular hard [ __ ] and Nicki and
JavaScript er have been working on it so
I will let you know more once it's ready
but it's basically going to be a place
where you can check out news about the
coolest things that are happening in
JavaScript and you'll be able to check
out repos and potentially some other
stuff we have some more ideas for it but
anyway that's that's what JavaScript AF
is maybe says so if you remember we were
talking about font sizes for mammy and
says it probably okay so a larger font
probably wouldn't
what I'm pursuing pursuing is to keep
learning says I'm retired I will keep
trying though I could finally get good
with practice okay yeah just you know
let me know there's anything I could do
you know to help and I definitely you
could definitely get good with practice
you know it's it's just a matter of
putting it in that time you know as a
says do you see yourself using PHP ever
we I do use some PHP when I have to do
WordPress plugins and I've done like
some basic file uploaders with PHP
before but I'm mainly I want to stick
with JavaScript so the PHP is not
something I want to pursue further I'm
comfortable with what I know about it
right now and I'm not I'm not really
interested in learning that much more
about it you know not that I don't have
anything against PHP but that's just not
the direction I want you know my my
learning to go in right now
oh okay Michael Michael reminded me that
so when I say Nikki Nikki is rook in the
chat so they're the same persons that
may have been confusing Karthik says how
do you remember what syntax to use when
coding up a project in JavaScript
considering javascript is confusing
language for many people it's it's just
practice right so I think any language
is confusing at first some may be more
than others but if you use it all the
time and you practice your you're gonna
remember things so I think that's really
all it is it's just you know you have
the practice it's gonna be less
confusing you'll remember more you'll
have to look up less and when you do
look things up you'll be able to find
the answer a lot faster because you
you'll know how to structure the
questions you'll know exactly like
you'll have a better idea of where to
look for an answer and you can only get
that through using the language practice
you know
okay all right I've got to the end of
the chat and I'm gonna wrap things up
here I'm gonna leave the office soon so
thank you all so much for watching and I
don't know I don't know if I'm able to
stream tomorrow and I may see y'all next
week probably on Monday so either way I
hope you have a great day and a great
weekend thanks again for watching and
I'll see you next time